[Musique]
histoire alors avant tout je voulais
dire que c'est une très grande fierté
pour moi de clôture et c'était d'extrême
2019 particulière parce que je vois là
j'ai passé une grande partie de ma vie à
rennes j'ai eu l'occasion de monter deux
projets musicaux
d'abord the popopopops puis heures voilà
j'ai décidé de m'exprimer vraiment à
travers ma musique ce soir parce que
parce que c'est ce que je suis un
artiste un musicien je vais tenter de
vous faire voyager à travers mes
influences
je commencerai bien sûr par la soul
parce que c'est
c'est la seule qui m'a donné envie de
chanter kim a envie qui m'a donné envie
de peut-être musiciens mais je vous
aurais aussi un peu de musique classique
parce que j'ai grandi avec la musique
classique sera d'ailleurs la première
fois pour moi que je vous jouerez un peu
de musique classique et j'ai composé
voilà merci merci encore une fois
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
je n'aime pas les snipers
0 à nani
granby
[Musique]
achkhabad
investisseurs son match à metz mawaï
une
[Musique]
m
enfin
[Musique]
m
on ne la connaît
[Musique]
l'année
arsène de can fly
[Musique]
une femme co2
non
d
mais si des
[Musique]
les vider
nos salles à la main de ce thème
cha smadja face des zones
m
[Musique]
lagardère
mais
non
car
[Musique]
m
amra gammée
et
rap
ban
m
n'a fait que traduire
non
[Musique]
la laci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que
non
m
à
[Musique]
merci beaucoup merci
[Applaudissements]
merci
merci avant de avant de vous quitter je
vais titre qui s'appelle we choose qui
est le titre qui était l'ouverture de
l'album 9 heures ce n'est pas un titre
que je choisis par hasard parce que
c'est un titre qui évoque la force qui
se cache derrière l'unité le
rassemblement mais aussi voilà chaque
femme et homme
lorsqu'ils croient en une cause et c'est
un titre qui m'a vraiment redonné de
l'espoir dans des moments où j'en avais
besoin
et j'espère qu'il en fera de même pour
vous voilà merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
oh oui chance nous avons vraiment
non
smoke meat chômage
[Musique]
witch ou
cadets
non
[Musique]
m
ça promet
[Musique]
ça
gwe
[Musique]
no
witch ou
ça
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
ça crie pas
hahaha
un groupe que dit
et
m
ça
grippe a
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]